[Music]
2023 is rewriting the rules of digital
design every click every scroll every
interaction is transforming taking on
New Dimensions and breaking boundaries
today we're pulling back the curtain on
the UI design trends that are not just
shaping the year but revolutionizing the
way we experience the web and as we
navigate through these Trends let us
know which trend is your favorite or if
there's something on the horizon we
should be on the lookout for while
exploring these Trends get our free UI
ux design Playbook packed with amazing
design tips and tricks that will elevate
your design game alright let's dive into
the first Trend animated 3D models
now think about the usual pictures we
see on websites pretty flat right well
2023 is pushing that aside for something
way cooler animated 3D models let you
see things from all angles almost like
you're holding them in your hand want to
see the back of a product before you buy
it no problem or maybe there's a cool
character on a site and you can watch it
move and do things it's like taking
what's great about video games and
putting it right on a web page but this
trend isn't just a visual treat
interactive 3D models leave a lasting
impression when visitors play around
with these models they're more likely to
recall the brand or product companies
are catching on and they're leaning into
this trend to present their offerings in
a way that's both Innovative and
memorable
let's dive into a detail of design that
might seem small but makes a huge impact
remember when the cursor was just an
arrow or a pointing hand 2023 has shaken
things up turning the humble cursor into
a design element of its own
custom cursors can range from Brand
specific icons to dynamically changing
shapes adapting to the content they
hover over it's like giving a personal
touch to a visitor's every move but
there's more to it than just Aesthetics
custom cursors can guide users highlight
key elements or provide additional
information now let's talk about a trend
that's turning the act of scrolling into
a cinematic experience scroll-based
animations
remember the times when scrolling down a
web page was just well scrolling not
anymore now as you scroll things move
shift and come to life but it's not just
about items popping up as you scroll
it's about storytelling the entire
Narrative of a website or digital
platform can be mapped out with each
scroll introducing new characters
unfolding stories or revealing crucial
information it's a dynamic way to make
sure the content isn't just consumed but
experienced scroll-based animations are
changing how we perceive time on
websites instead of static stagnant
Pages we're getting fluid evolving
digital stories where the user decides
the pace and in 2023 this is quickly
becoming the norm rather than the
exception
[Music]
ever notice those soft glowing colors
lighting up some of your favorite
websites they add a modern vibrant touch
to sites giving them that edge without
being too in your face neon Mists are
truly shaping the 2023 web design game
whether it's to highlight a button add a
cool backdrop or just give a futuristic
feel neon Mists make things pop but
that's not all neon Mists can actually
influence user Behavior a subtle glowing
highlight around a call to action or a
soft neon Haze in the background can
guide the user's eyes to specific
content or sections it's a fusion of
Aesthetics and functionality
minimalism has been around for a while
but is making a big splash again in 2023
in a digital world bustling with
information and flashing ads sometimes
less truly is more minimalism is all
about stripping away the excess and
focusing on what's essential but don't
mistake it for being boring or too plain
a minimalist design can be bold
impactful and Incredibly effective
minimalist design usually has clean
lines limited color palettes and
purposeful white spaces every element on
a minimalist website or app has a clear
purpose there's no decoration for the
sake of decoration this means faster
load times more direct messaging and a
better user experience overall on top of
that Brands embracing minimalism are
often perceived as being more genuine
transparent and trustworthy lastly let's
move on to a trend that's hard to miss
huge typography in 2023 designers aren't
just using text to convey a message
they're turning it into a visual
Powerhouse words are no longer confined
to the sidelines they're front and
center dominating screens and making
bold statements this trend is about more
than just size it's about playing with
font weights Styles and compositions to
create designs that are both
eye-catching and impactful when
typography takes the lead every letter
and word becomes an integral part of the
design sometimes even replacing
traditional imagery this means designers
have to be more selective and thoughtful
about their word choices ensuring they
convey the intended message effectively
that's a wrap on the best UI design
Trends in 2023 if you've got thoughts or
predictions of your own drop a comment
below thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video